[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui fred
sa chair réalisateur est professeur de
cinéma à la sorbonne pour son livre je
veux faire du cinéma petit manuel de
survie dans le septième art qui créé
toute une polémique en belgique et qui
pourrait très bien ancrée et une en
france on va voir pourquoi
billy bellegarde et masse car le duo n'a
moreau qui sort son premier album cassia
pop et et jean noël lloze pour sa
biographie andy warhol le renard blanc
sur l'un des artistes les plus
emblématiques du 20e siècle et l'on
commence tout de suite par notre époque
qu'est ce qui caractérise ce début de
xxième siècle voici vos réponses en
images on commence par celle de journée
à el niño est ce que ça représente
ça représente les bûcher funéraire en
inde à delhi en ce moment et pour moi
c'est toute l'horreur de cette pandémie
et la manière dont cette crise est gérée
en inde avec ses trains de l'oxygène qui
vont et viennent y en a pas assez pour
tout le monde et je crois que ce n'est
rien les informations qui nous parvient
en fait ne sont rien par rapport à ce
que me disent les amis indiens et pour
moi c'est voilà ça me brise le coeur en
fête cette photo est alors il faut se
rappeler que en am la tradition est
évidemment de brûler les corps des morts
c'est d'aimer la pandémie 1
voilà c'est dans les rues à l'âne c'est
vraiment dans des conditions tragiques
pour les familles et pour tout le monde
alors voici là l'image choisie par le
duo n'a moreau est ce que c'est ce que
vous avez une idée j'ai l'impression que
ça pourrait être du savon alors c'est
quoi alors ce qu est une poche de
cocktails sont vides
c'est à dire donc ça se boit c'est une
boisson et c'est quelque chose qu'il
n'aurait jamais existé avant on a un
petit bar à côté de chez nous qui
s'appelle le co est en fait qui vend ses
cd magnifique cocktail que normalement
on voit al attar au bas et que là en
fait on emporte à la maison on a juste à
couper le bout et puis ensuite à
savourer voilà c'est formidable gens
n'avaient jamais vu et et vous dit que
ça s'appelle comment alors alors le le
bar qui fait ça s'appelle le
oui c'est dans le xviiie à paris
d'accord mais y avait il n'a pas encore
trouvé de nom au fait qu'on emporte un
cocktail sous vide pour le boire chez
soi on n'a pas encore donné non à ce
nouvel usage non c'est pas encore tout à
fait baptiser je me trouvais et rien ne
dit que cela va perdurer au-delà de
l'aude la de la pandémie mais allez
savoir
il ya tellement de choses qu'on va
conserver après que ça peut en faire
partie on voit maintenant la la photo
choisie par frédéric sojcher c'est dans
la série les selphy on en a eu quelques
unes
quelques uns plus exactement depuis le
début de cette émission alors pourquoi
ce pourquoi ce self il a fait par une
femme frédéric sojcher je pourrais par
un homme aussi par un couple la question
c'est celle du narcissisme de notre
époque et que je ne poserai à la
création parce que les écrivains les
cinéastes et artistes peuvent parler
d'eux à la première personne n'ait à
condition de se dépasser
trouver la bonne distance hélas souvent
dans les personnes qui ont laissé les
fils et c'est juste un ego sans aucune
création et sans aucun intérêt et je
voudrais aussi dire que quand je donne
cours à mes étudiants la sorbonne au
cinéma maintenant grâce aux appareils de
téléphone on peut on peut filmer très
facilement mais ça ne suffit pas la
technique doit être au service d'un
propos ya pas de trop pour la technique
d'un connecteur est bien commençons
[Musique]
dingue ce cher vous êtes belle je vous
enseigner le cinéma à la sorbonne vous
avez réalisé quatre longs métrages dont
hitler à hollywood
vous avez écrit plusieurs livres dont un
petit chef-d'oeuvre ma base sur le film
qui est réédité on va en parler et je
veux faire du cinéma petit manuel de
survie dans le septième art qui vient de
paraître dans les poches belge et qui
crée la polémique en belgique
alors pourquoi pourquoi la polémique pas
pour une raison simple vous êtes le
premier au fond à mettre les pieds dans
le plat
un frédéric sojcher alors décrivez-nous
en quelques mots le plat alors je
m'attendais à ce que tout le monde ne
sont pas au niveau de ce que j'écris
puisque puisque quelque part je donne un
avis critique sur le système de
production mais je m'attendais pas à ce
que ça prenne une telle ampleur puisque
en belgique a beaucoup beaucoup de
presse la libre belgique qu'un grand
quotidien les trois croix de pages le
soir deux fois deux pages le vif qu'elle
faisait de madère six pages ont consacré
toutes sortes de réactions de la
profession et des journalistes et qui
s'interrogent sur effectivement comment
fonctionne le cinéma de l'intérieur et
donc c'était ma volonté
ce livre d'abord qu'ils soient
accessibles à tous pas aux seuls initiés
j'essaye toujours dans mes livres de
pouvoir qui soit qui puisse être
accessible à des les victoires qui ne
sont pas du milieu du cinéma et donc à
une aventure qui est celle de comment on
fait un film et comment fonctionne le
système de financement
effectivement je pose à travers mon
parcours que je ne peux parler que de ce
que je connais j'ai moi même et des
membres de la commission d'avancé sur
recette en belgique donc j'ai vécu de
l'intérieur
donc je raconte quelles sont les
questions qui se posent sur le
financement des films est ce qu est ce
que ça fonctionne de manière idéale ou
au contraire est-ce qu'on pourrait
améliorer les choses
alors vous décrivez ce système comme une
machine à broyer où ce sont toujours les
mêmes qui passent à la caisse
alors évidemment ça ça fait fulminer ça
fait fulminer parce que cette
dénonciation est grave ça veut dire que
d'une certaine manière de l'argent
public est détournée
ou en tout cas habilement répartis entre
un petit nombre de dents entre un petit
nombre de gens et donc forcément au
détriment des autres machines c'est
yvonne un thème que j'emploie qui est
pas propre à la belgique si on regarde
la france et qu'on voit la fois ce qui
est le pays où plus de premier long
métrage chaque année réaliser si on se
projette vingt ans plus tard il ya
seulement moins de 10% des cinéastes qui
ont fait un premier long métrage qui
sont toujours en activité de près ce
qu'on peut penser que 90% des fines
herbes qui compte un premier long
métrage sont forcément inaltérée fans
peuvent pas continuer donc quelque chose
de très violents d'un cinéma et sur
d'entonnoir où il ya beaucoup d'appelés
peu d'élus et même dans les élus eux qui
arrivent à persévérer et donc si je me
pose la question de comment trouver un
système plus vertueux notamment car
aujourd'hui il ya d'autres manières de
faire des films il ya les plateformes
il ya les séries et donc n'essayez pas
moyen de trouver pour à la fois la jeune
génération car je suis très intéressé
par les jeunes cinéastes mais aussi pour
les plus âgées car je pense que c'est ce
n'est pas ce cinéma vient l'idée de
jeter comme des kleenex les personnes de
50 ans parce que ton pas une succès
suffisant me paraît quelque chose de
très violents et une société e contre
laquelle ton se battre à mon avis et
donc le cinéma de symptôme de quelque
chose de plus profond qui habite notre
société et qu'il commande ne pas gâcher
des talents parce que je pense qu'il ya
effectivement beaucoup de cinéastes sur
les talents qui n'arrivent plus à faire
des films parce que il ya cette
concurrence violente et il coûte tout de
suite réussir donne l'exemple des frères
dardenne en belgique rappelle que
plusieurs palme d'or à cannes
leurs deux premiers longs métrages ont
été des échecs je parle factuellement
c'est-à-dire échec en tant en nombre de
spectateurs donc pas de jugement sur
leurs films et les films ne sont pas
sortis en france et on fait juste
quelques centaines de spectateurs en
belgique
j'aime pourtant réussi à prendre une
troisième fois l'avant sur cette belle
pour la promesse la promesse est un film
qui sera à cannes à la quinzaine des
réalisateurs et qu'il a véritablement
marqué le début de leur cas
et si on leur a même pas donné cette
troisième chance sans doute n'aurait
jamais dû palme d'or et sans doute des
fare alais ne serait pas devenu ce qui
te sont aujourd'hui donc je pense qu'il
faut sortir d'une société où il ya un
couperet oui tout de suite on n'a pas la
réussite
on est voué à l'échec c'est vrai que ce
que vous décrivez aussi dans le système
belge c'est quelque chose qui a changé
qui a évolué du temps des dardenne on
leur a laissé une troisième chance
peut-être dit vous qu'aujourd'hui on la
leur laisserait pas mais ce que vous
décrivez plus généralement frédéric
sojcher c'est une oligarchie au fond où
l'on à un certain nombre de millions
d'euros à se partager c'est pas un
nombre illimité et que donc on est
obligé au fond pour pour décider de les
attribuer à un tel at elle est at elle
de dire que tous les autres ne les
méritent pas mais c'est quand même une
ligue archi où on se copte au fond et le
système est le même en france même si en
france on peut faire du cinéma sans
passer par le cnc qui est l'équivalent
de votre de votre chez plus comment ça
s'appelle en belgique centre du cinéma
voilà il ya de très grands réalisateurs
en france qui n'ont jamais eu l'aide du
cnc et qui aurait essuyé que tout comme
vous puisque vous raconter les quinze
refus que vous avez essuyées de la part
du centre du cinéma belge
certains de nos réalisateurs très
célèbre pourraient eux aussi raconté
comment ils se sont fait rejeter mais
quoi qu'il en soit c'est ça que je
voudrais vous décriviez c'est
l'oligarchie au fond ça c'est une
véritable ligue archi c'est des gens du
cinéma qui choisissent quels sont ceux
qui vont pouvoir à leur tour faire du
cinéma
ce propos de l'exercice et c'est pas
souri que j'emploie mais je ferai deux
petites nuances la première sur la
belgique c'est que j'aime les cinéastes
belges sont soutenus par la commission
du film je ne suis pas en train de dire
que ne font pas les aider j'ai même
coordonner un ouvrage sur les frères
dardenne
jal et inès comme google earth comme
joaquin la force comme jacobins normal
qu'ils ont été à cannes aux différentes
sections et qui seront soutenus par le
centre du cinéma
je trouve ça formidable qu'ils puissent
continuer à être soutenus je ne voudrais
pas opposé décidé à ce qu'ils sont
reconnus à tous les autres qui
n'arrivent pas à joindre
ne voudrais pas rentrer dans ce débat là
la deuxième petite nuance c'est que en
france
il veut une grande différence avec la
belgique d'abord on est dans une
beaucoup de large échelle la france n'a
plus grand pays en nombre d'habitants de
spectateurs en salle et surtout il n'y a
pas que le cnc
il ya d'autres sources de financement
possibles tandis qu'en belgique
effectivement on ne peut pas faire de
longs métrages sans l'aide du centre du
cinéma c'est un vrai problème
le fait qu'ils aient un monopole ou une
obligation de passer par un guichet de
financement en particulier à mon avis tu
crées une forme de dysfonctionnements
vous dites également que au fond dans ce
système un système qui crème conformisme
parce qu'on retient plus facilement un
projet qui plaît moyennement à tout le
monde plutôt qu'un projet qui divise
or ce sont en tout cas au cinéma mais en
arts en général ce sont toujours les
projets les plus audacieux qui sont les
plus intéressants ceux qui resteront un
exemple que vous citez sais c'est arrivé
près de chez vous célèbre film belge qui
a valu la découverte de benoît
poelvoorde
voilà un film extrêmement segmentant qui
a pu être détesté par beaucoup de gens
adoré par beaucoup d'autres qui
évidemment n'a pas eu des das fortement
l'ap
bien sûr on fait il aurait pas eu non
plus le cnc c'est certain voilà ce genre
de film jamais jamais ne sera encouragée
et on pourrait citer toute une liste de
deux films très important dans
l'histoire du cinéma qui n'auraient
jamais été retenu parce qu'on retient la
moyenne donc je suis médiocratie au fond
ce qui est intéressant avec cette
arrivée deux pas de chez vous qui vaut
moins qu'un grand film c'est qu'il donne
un film culte même aux états unis
quentin tarantino par exemple adore ce
film c'est que il a été refusé la voir
sur cette belge mais par contre dès
qu'il était sélectionné à la semaine de
la critique à cannes
là il a reçu une aide à la finition par
saccades
il a quand même une aide publique et
donc on voit bien le côté effet vitrine
qui existe et je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que vous dites
la question c'est quand il ya un projet
qui divise parce qu'il est singulier et
bien ils risquent de ne pas avoir la
majorité des bois quand une commission
et donc c'est
les projets de consensuel où les projets
de cinéastes déjà reconnu qu'ils vont
passer
et donc c'était une vraie question sur
la démocratie culturelle comment faire
pour que des projets atypiques des
projets hors norme des projets de qui
par définition ne peuvent pas plaire à
tout le monde ici aussi être soutenus
mais c'est le problème au fond de l'aide
en général et quand on a un secteur
comme le cinéma en belgique où ou en
france subventionnés en fête ou en tout
cas il ya un circuit qui lui permet de
récolter de l'argent public c'est
comment est-ce qu'on attribue cet argent
public
au fond ce sera un éternel problème tant
qu'on a affaire à des groupes on avait
affaire autrefois à des groupes
producteurs à cigares avec des bretelles
ils jouaient leur chemise sur un film
c'était leur problème et avec ça on a
fait des chefs-d'oeuvre quand il y avait
les grands studios
c'était pareil ils voulaient gagner de
l'argent mais avec ce système là dirigés
par des gens qui aimait passionnément le
cinéma on a fait des chefs-d'oeuvre au
fond avec le système qui existe
aujourd'hui en belgique comme en france
on fait moins de chefs-d'oeuvre et ça et
ça et ça énerve tout le monde au fonds
ce système là favorise le conformisme la
médiocratie
ne favorise pas les chefs-d'oeuvre t
peut alors en tout cas moi ce que je
retiens c'est l'envié et jade est basse
le cinéma quand on a envie de quelque
chose et quand on incinère doit avoir
envie de son film et non seulement
d'avoir l'accord ce communiqué est en
vie à une production une équipe à des
acteurs fédérer tout le monde autour du
parc du film donc leur vie et le pari si
ya pas de lorgies n'essayez pas de paris
il ya peu de chances qu'une oeuvre d'art
tout est dans le domaine
cinématographique intéressante à
l'arrivée est-ce qu'il faut remis dames
c'est quand un producteur
vous quittez les producteurs
hollywoodiens il aimait ce qu'il faisait
il avait une volonté de rentabiliser de
rentabilité il y avait aussi un amour du
cinéma c'était pas des personnes qui
venaient des écoles de commerce comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui davantage dans
les sources de financement privées qui
sont dans un studio hollywoodien comme
il pourrait être patron d'une usine
automobile
ce qu'il faut c'est l' envie de cinéma à
partager et le pari et chaque pari
chaque film est un prototype donc chaque
fois c'est un risque aussi cette notion
du risque est un essentiel pour caen qui
nous sort une si il se chargerait qu'on
dise quelques mots également de main
basse sur le film qui vient d'être
réédité lui aussi dans les poches belge
alors c'est un film c'est un livre
formidable qu'on lit comme les éditions
genèse en fêtant la collection
rochebelle de ces les éditions jeunesse
pardon pardon et sa livre formidable je
disais qu'il se lit comme un polar et
c'est un livre sur un des grands tabous
du cinéma quand le tournage se passe mal
c'est arrivé très souvent dans
l'histoire du cinéma
on le sait quand on lit les livres de
cinéma on ne sait pas en général c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on raconte au
public et et vous vous vous êtes fait
carrément volé votre premier film j'ai
fini par le récupérer mais pendant un
certain temps sur le tournage vous
voulez fait voler littéralement essais
et c'est ce que vous racontez
minutieusement et beaucoup d'humour une
certaine distance vous avez vous attendu
quelques années avant de pouvoir le
raconter c'est un livre qui est devenu
très célèbre
dans le milieu du cinéma on parlait de
benoît poelvoorde pour lui c'est un
livre culte par exemple n'était pourtant
pas sur le tournage mais il adore ce
livre comme beaucoup de gens bertrand
tavernier on avait fait la préface vous
l'avez en le rééditant aujourd'hui quand
vous le camp vous le sortez stains c'est
un mauvais souvenir toujours vous en
avez fait autre chose à présent dans
votre dans votre dans votre esprit
mais je pense que tout ce qui nous
arrive de mal dans la vie donc si ça
dépasse le cinéma il faut le recycler et
en tirer partie c'est une sorte de
philosophie de vie dont le tournage
était un enfer les grâce à ce tournage
il ya plein de choses sur la vie sur la
dynamique de groupe et j plein de
cinéastes aussi qui ne m'aurait pas
parler si j'allais mater ce livre des
cinéastes très célèbres dont je tairai
les noms mais qui ont commencé à
raconter chacun un petit secret de
tournage je me suis rendu compte que
tous les cinéastes qui ont fait un
certain nombre de films ont à un moment
ou un autre rencontre est un grave
problème sur un tournage et des finances
est un sujet tabou
d'où l'intérêt je pense d'en parler
parce que c'est ça montre quelque chose
sur la dynamique de groupe sur l'équipe
sur le cinéma est donc ce dépassement
personnel
bertrand tavernier sinon on n'aurait
sans doute pas fait la préface et je
voudrais dire ici que je ne savais pas
qu'il allait si mal je savais qu'il
était malade puisqu'il est mort
récemment et deux mois avant sa mort on
a eu un dernier échange de mails puisque
évidemment je l'avais retisser de la
ressortie du livre et il m'a dit quelque
chose qui m'a beaucoup touché il m'a dit
qu'ils croyaient en moi comme cinéaste
et qui m'invitait à poursuivre le combat
des films ça à temps après et pourquoi
ça ne me touche beaucoup parce que main
basse sur le film c'est mon premier long
métrage c'est la descente aux enfers
c'est une catastrophe et trois ans après
je fais un documentaire qui en sélection
officielle à cannes
et c'est ça aussi le cinéma c'est des
montagnes russes on n'est pas condamné à
l'échec
on n'est pas certain qu'en fait il
réussit dans nos frais le nôtre par la
suite et c'est toujours le combat qui
reste le moteur l'envi le terme si les
mains envers et contre tout dans ma base
sur le film j'ai dit c'est ce clip comme
un polar parce qu'on sent le noeud
coulant qui se resserrent lentement
lentement autour du cou du dur et les
acteurs de ce jeune réalisateur dont
c'est le premier film sur une île
grecque et on voit bien
comment ce noeud coulant peut se
resserrer le manque d'argent un
producteur inexistant une équipe en
participation et le fait qu'il soit en
participation ils ont l'impression c'est
que c'est le kolkhoze que chacun peut
donner son avis sur la marche du film et
puis le machiavélisme de l'acteur
principal qui va qui va essayer de voler
film de devenir le réalisateur à la
place du réalisateur et qui veulent pas
revenir provisoirement
évidemment tout ça au fond n'est
possible que parce qu'il ya un certain
nombre de données je les dis le manque
d'argent c'est capital mais aussi parce
que soi même en tant que réalisateur on
fait des erreurs et voulait raconter ses
erreurs vous les analyser au fur et à
mesure vous avez pas assez pris de temps
pour discuter avec untel ou avec une
telle vous n'êtes pas assis au bon
endroit au moment à la cantine etc etc
au fond c'est fait de toutes petites
choses l'enfer d'un tournage
heureusement je n'ai qu'une paradis des
tournages par la suite et argent donc
c'est le seul encore que j'ai connue
jusqu'ici j'espère le dernier mais c'est
vrai que c'est ce qui est fascinant
c'est comment la mécanique se met en
place
et comme vous le dites l effet des
petits détails des petites choses et non
principal défaut je pense mon principal
tort sur ce film c'est de ne pas m'être
rendu compte
un civil qui avait un problème si on
prend la métaphore d'un incendie qui
l'attendait dans une pièce on peut les
dan une fois qu'il se propage dans toute
la maison c'est beaucoup plus difficile
donc il faut tout de suite être
conscient des problèmes quand il y en a
pour trouver des solutions et c'est en
cela que j'invite les jeunes cinéastes à
réfléchir aux problèmes qui peuvent se
tourner sur un tournage où les anticiper
et justement que ces problèmes ne
viennent pas trop trop important et du
coup ingérable voilà merci frédéric
sojcher je veux faire du cinéma emma
basse sur le film
ça vient de paraître en poche je veux
faire du cinéma et en lui un inédit
[Musique]
billy bellegarde et masse car vous
former le duo n'a moreau qui sort son
premier album cassia pop et pourquoi
n'at moreau qui rappelle fernando pessoa
et que signifie cassia pop et enfin j'ai
peut-être commencer sur srna moureaux
c'est exactement ça c'est vraiment une
référence à pessoa en fait on fait de la
musique pour donner une forme d'oralité
à de la poésie et renouer avec les
formes orales de poésie mais en étant
aussi complètement investi dans notre
époque et donc avec une dimension
musique électronique ont dit assistée
par ordinateur et donc tout notre
travail c'est de de naviguer comme ça
entre une veine poétique qui nous qui
nous est très cher parce que avant de
faire de la musique nous on faisait
aussi beaucoup de littérature et moi
j'ai même fait un doctorat en
littérature donc l'idée c'était de
rester avec tout ce qui nous a portés
delà de cette veine littéraire est
d'être au service d'une musique parce
que on est maintenant d'aider des
personnes de la scène on vient à la base
du cabaret et du théâtre et la musique
c'est vraiment notre rencontre à toutes
les deux c'est ce projet namoureux c'est
vraiment aussi cette rencontre entre
billy bellegarde et mascaret donc on
trouvait que d'avoir ce mot dynamo qui
veut dire aussi tout simplement en
portugais d'une part un flirt donc une
de ce qui est plus triviale et en même
temps paix soit il amène une autre
définition qui dit que c'est de l'amour
qui a conscience
un amour intense qui a une conscience de
la finitude de toute chose et donc on
est mais aussi 7
cette dimension incandescente puis pour
katia pop et peut-être vie
oui la cia pop est alors pour le coup
c'est une autre inspiration
ça vient du livre de monique wittig qui
s'appelle les guerrières et dans cette
épopée les guerrières en fait il ya par
moment des grandes pages où il ya que
des prénoms en fait de ces dites
guerrières qui sont les unes après les
uns après les autres qu'ils sont en
liste et cassia pop et ses deux prénoms
de ces guerrières
donc ils sont tirés à des du livre de
monique wittig tout de suite un extrait
du clip
l'une de vos chansons sur cet album
c'est en forme de diamant
ramasse me dis tu
[Musique]
ramasse
raccompagné poignet contre la saison
les tentes millet de sedan cher monsieur
[Musique]
ce
répète
très -
me dit il
répète
après mois
[Musique]
lorna moreau pour moi c'est le premier
groupe formé par deux femmes qui
s'aiment
à ma connaissance ça n'existait pas
avant vous est ce que vous avez fait des
recherches
on a un peu regardés alors c'est c'est
obligé que ça existe parce que c'est
toujours difficile de visibilité mais
voilà c'est à dire que c'est peut-être
le premier groupe en tout cas là en
france où nous déjà on s'affirme aussi
comme étant un couple qui s'aime et qui
fait de la musique c'est à dire que
normalement dans une démarche on va dire
plus mark était de la musique c'est pas
ça qu'il faudrait mettre en avant mais
nous on est dans une démarche
complètement incandescente de la musique
et donc on fait de la musique comme on
est on aime beaucoup par exemple
s'inspirer de cette phrase de barbara
qui dit je suis une femme qui chante et
d'ailleurs cette phrase de deux femmes
qui s'aiment qui chante ça vient aussi
c'est aussi un hommage à barbara con
qu'on aime très fort et donc oui c'est
vrai que mais il faudrait approfondir
les recherches et avec un vrai beau
travail dgt archives s'assortirait c'est
sûr bibi bellegarde
bah oui absolument que je ne sais pas si
on est les premières gens j'en doute
mais en tout cas c'est vrai que
visibiliser notre amour un peu au
premier plan aussi de ça c'est hyper
important pour nous et c'est pour ça
aussi qu'on s'appelle la mort on s'est
vraiment une manière de dire qu'on
existe qu'on est là et puis aussi du
coup de dire à des personnes qui sont
seules qu' on est plein en fait on va
voir bassam ouvre forcément un des
champs d'expérimentation et de réflexion
tout à fait sans précédent ont fait une
pause et on en parle juste après
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec billy
bellegarde et bhaskar qui forment le duo
n'a moreau je disais juste avant la
pause que s'ouvre à vous un champ à la
fois de réflexion et d'expérimentation
inédit c'est vrai c'est à partir du
moment où on est un groupe avec deux
formés d'un couple de femmes qui
s'aiment
on peut raconter des histoires que
personne ne racontaient jusqu'avant
est-ce que vous en est ce que vous vous
en rendez compte est ce que vous l'avez
déjà expérimenté oui en fait je crois
qu'on n'est pas forcément les premières
à raconter ses histoires mais en tout
cas on en est le relais et l'écho et
monique wittig c'est vraiment une
hauteur qui est très importante pour
nous et qui est primordial en fait est
crucial dans l'écriture de l'album parce
que justement quand on a découvert son
travail on s'est rendu compte que on
avait des racines en tant que femme qui
s'aiment que en fait il y avait déjà des
histoires et qu'il suffisait juste de
l'est de les écrire et pour les faire
exister elle elle dit elle disait ça
ainsi si tu ne te souviens pas un vente
et donc c'est ce qu'on a fait aussi avec
avec cet album cassia pop essaie de
raconter effectivement ces histoires et
de se donner des des racines en fait
tout simplement score et puis aussi en
fait on est en faisant de la musique
nous on fait de la musique pour surtout
pour de la scène c'est vraiment
l'endroit où on est là on se sent le
mieux alors on aime énormément de
travail en studio mais c'est vrai que
cet endroit du partage le fait qu'on
soit ensemble c'est notre point de
départ à nous donc qui est pris comme tu
dit billy dans cette danse relais là
avec des personnes qui nous sont très
chères comme monique vite il ya audrey
leur dos il l'a poids est américaine est
en fait toutes ces personnes là sont
comme des voix qui en fait d'un coup
nous permettre de mettre des mots sur
des ressentis sur des émotions qui sont
floues parce que en fait on ne se
reconnaît pas dans on va dire les
discours et et le
le discours un peu nationale ou en tout
cas habituel on se reconnaît pas dans
les histoires d'amour pour nous raconte
à l'école on ne se reconnaît en fait on
ne se reconnaît pas dans tout le dans
une grande partie déjà de ce qui
s'appelle le patrimoine culturel et donc
en fait d'un coup d'avoir accès à toutes
ces personnes mais je pense aussi à
quelqu'un comme virginie despentes qui
est très importante pour nous d'avoir
accès à toute cette d'abord cette
littérature parce que c'est par les mots
que nous en commandent qu'on a commencé
à faire de la musique ça nous a permis
de respirer en fait de souffler et et
pourquoi on n'a pas écrit des livres et
qu'on a fait plutôt de la musique ça
c'est parce que c'est c'est notre
endroit de la scène c'est notre endroit
aussi de compositions de de deux
chanteuses
en tout cas il ya vraiment cette idée
que on est on est on est comme des
phares en fait qui balaye ont un peu
comme ça des lumières pour dire bah oui
nous ne sommes pas seuls oui nous ne
sommes pas
nous nous essayons d'être de moins en
moins isolé et nous sommes aussi une
pluralité énorme c'est à dire que nous
on n'est pas représentante de toutes
déjà on dit des femmes qui s'aiment et
il ya un an nous on est très proche
aussi de toutes les causes on en fait
qu'ils sont celles aussi des personnes
trans transgenres transsexuels aussi que
c'est pas le tout la même chose et tout
ce travail là c'est un travail
monumental qui attend notre notre siècle
et dont il faut juste s'en saisir
laisser la parole aussi aux bonnes
personnes ne pas trop se crisper et ça
ça passe par un bon morceau de musique
aussi quoi voilà tout trouvé ces échos
et le clip que vous en avez tiré avec
des images des images souvent peu connus
d'ailleurs parce qu'au fond le mouvement
lesbien est extrêmement peu connu il est
beaucoup moins bien connu que beaucoup
d'autres mouvements contestataires
né dans l'est dans les années 60
bah on regarde tout de suite un extrait
de deux échos
sauna
à
et
[Musique]
à
j'ai un don
moi c'est comme une plateforme
m
porter des verres
oh
m
[Musique]
ou est ce que vous avez trouvé toutes
ces images d'abord et ça c'est ma
première question d'où elles sortent
toutes ces images on connaît pas alors
oui alors il ya des en fait ce qu'on
voulait faire c'était un travail aussi
de temporalité donc en fait il ya des
images qui viennent
on est allés questionner des
journalistes qu'on connaît qui en fait
nous ont renvoyés vers des fonds
d'archivés qui sont souvent des fonds
d'archivés étrangers parce qu'en france
est assez compliqué il n'y a pas encore
il ya un gros travail d'archivés qui est
en cours mais c'était plus simple en
fait de trouver les fonds qui venait
plutôt les usa où il ya aussi des photos
qui viennent des pays bas et il ya des
photos de france et photos de frans
masson celle de gaël matata qui est une
une photographe et qui en fait qui est
une amie aussi et qui du coup en fait
nous à perdre nous a donné accès à ces
photos est donc pour nous c'était un
moyen voire l'a22 de montrer que là on
voit on reconnaît aussi on connaît on
reconnaît il ya plus inconnu que le
soldat sa femme ça c'est le premier acte
de féminisme en france sont des images
en fait qui devrait être presque aussi
connu que je sais pas moi tout ça ça
fait partie vraiment de l'histoire de
france mais et voilà ces images qui pour
l'instant sont encore plus tôt dans
l'est comme dans les placards et donc
voilà l'idée c'était de mélanger comme
ça et de et de m me mettre un quai 1
un jalon d'histoire dans l'histoire de
france en fait parce que c'est
l'histoire de france
l'album s'intitule kashyap ep le groupe
cdh à morrow on le retrouve dans tous
les bacs et on vous attend sur scène
parce qu'on l'a bien entendu c'est
d'abord fait pour la scène
votre répertoire et que parfois on a
l'impression que vous devez de vous
sentir un peu en cage en ce moment donc
vivement que les scènes rouvre
[Musique]
léo vous êtes l'auteur de plusieurs
biographies des demandes charles-roux de
karen blixen où d'hubert de givenchy
aujourd'hui vous publié chez alary andy
warhol le renard blanc pourquoi le
renard blanc d'abord le renard blanc
parce que c'est son surnom qui lui a été
donnée par paulette goddard la muse de
chaplin avec qui il a entretenu une
relation assez assez compliqué et je
trouve que ça résume bien c'est l'idée
que je me fais de warhol à renard et il
brûlera cause à la mairie naturellement
parce qu'il était chauve il avait des
perruques en acrylique argenté et donc
ça joue sur les deux tableaux
et ça nous rappelle que l'apparence de
d'andy warhol très célèbre un tel qu'on
le voit là noir et blanc des lunettes
cette perruque blanche peroxydée au fond
tout ça est une construction une
construction d'ailleurs relativement
tardive 1 quand on lit votre livre on
s'aperçoit que c'est à l'âge de 32 ans
environ qu'il se transforme de cette
manière là il se il ce design au fond
mais vous le décrivez enfants et même
adolescent il est solitaire et les
techniques les enfants de la classe que
considère comme un monstre et aux faux
c'est quelqu'un qui se replient dans le
dessin dans le cinéma et dans la prière
exactement son enfance a été vraiment
gangréné par la maladie et la pauvreté
il avait là ce qu'on appelait la danse
de saint-guy à l'époque l'accord et idan
âme
c'est pour ça qu'il était dépigmenter
qu'il avait perdu ses cheveux c'était
c'est une maladie très grave que l'on
peut guérir par une injection de
pénicilline mais en 35 ça n'existait pas
elle a commencé à circuler en 41 donc ça
a conditionné son enfance et c'est vrai
qu'il s'est réfugié dans le dessin dans
la prière et dans le cinéma
ce sont les trois axes tout au long de
sa vie il va devenir un peintre un
réalisateur et être un croyant jusqu'à
la fin de ses jours cesser son refuge
c'est le seul endroit où il n'est pas
agressé en fait par le monde extérieur
parce qu'il a échoué à devenir un homme
normal dans les mains de l'amérique des
années 40 50 de l'amérique des mad men
il a essayé dans un premier temps et il
a vu que c'était un échec
donc il a réussi à prendre le pouvoir en
dramatisant son apparence en dramatisant
sa bizarrerie en la mettant en scène
donc c'est physique mais c'est aussi sa
voix par exemple aucun des biographes
jusqu'à présent n'a pu expliquer ce
qu'était la voile warhol et j'en ai
parlé à lee radziwill la soeur de
jacqueline kennedy qui m'a dit je vais
vous donner l'explication il me l'a
donné quand ma soeur a at-elle attendre
et la parole pendant la campagne
présidentielle
warhol a dit cette voie c'est la voix
parfaite c'est la voie que je veux le
don qu'il apaisa my bouvier voice ma
voix bouvier et c'est une voix qui l'a
adoptée jusqu'à la fin de ses jours dans
toutes ses interviews une voix comme ça
de petite fille mondaine est essoufflé
mais c'était tellement étrange avec son
physique et avec son apparence avec ce
qu'il avait à dire donc c'est un c'est
un collage il est il est un collage de
différentes choses comme ça qui l'a mis
au point pour devenir ce que ce
personnage c'est il y avait son
apparence physique et naturellement on
en reparlera son atelier la première
factory argenté ce qu'on avait les deux
combinés ont donné un pouvoir illimité à
cet homme
arrêtons nous un instant sur cette voie
la voie de jackie kennedy en fait que tu
imites andy warhol vous êtes le premier
a donné cette explication dieu sait si
on a écrit sur warhol depuis assez
longtemps maintenant c'est la première
fois que j'entends cette explication là
et c'est vrai quand on écoute la voix de
warhol dans ses interviews audio
fouilles limite jackie kennedy et qui
est une voie très célèbre personne ne
s'en était rendu compte
chez un homme c'est à dire que le fait
d'adapter cette voix qui s'y
symptomatique à lui a donné attirer le
regard
les gens tendaient l'oreille parce qu'il
se dit qu'est ce que c'est que cet
énergumène sait ce qu'il a à nous dire
mais comme vous dites il ya eu beaucoup
de livres sur warhol est le seul intérêt
d'un nouveau livre c'est d'apporter de
nouveaux éclairages donc celui-là c'est
un parmi tant d'autres parce que j'ai
travaillé pendant 30 ans j'ai interviewé
tellement de proches qui toujours
n'avait pas parlé à d'autres biographe
donc c'est pour ça aussi c'était pour
éclairer de l'intérieur et l'humaniser
au fond alors j'en aliot et vous
rappeler qu'avant de devenir l'artiste
très célèbre qu'il est devenu assez
tardivement finalement un verre de 32 33
ans de 22 à 32 ans c'est un dessinateur
publicitaire un illustrateur
publicitaire plus exactement ni warhol
qui connaît beaucoup de succès
d'ailleurs il réussit très très vite
en dix ans il va acheter une maison sur
lexington avenue dans lequel il va vivre
avec sa mère et j'ai sorti ces trois
pochettes de disques du fameux label
blue note
parce que ce sont trois pochette
illustrée par andy warhol à l'époque et
où l'on voit au fond ce qui était le
vrai style d'andy warhol parce que tout
ce qu'on veut ce qu'il va faire par la
suite ça n'est pas dessiné par andy
warhol
ça n'est même pas peint par andy warhol
en fait quand on le dessine andy warhol
ça donne ça ça c'est le vrai style dandy
warhols et c'est un style qui a du
succès dans l'estrie illustration
publicitaires mais qui donnera jamais en
tant qu'art exactement et d'ailleurs il
va le payer chèrement cette immense
succès parce qu'effectivement comme vous
l'avez dit il peut acheter un hôtel
particulier il vit très bien mais dans
le monde de l'art il a une réputation
frivole parce qu'ils travaillent pour
les magazines en particulier des
magazines de mode aussi ce qui lui ne le
ne le dérange absolument pas mais les
galeristes sérieux hésite
évidemment à part a présenté son travail
et donc il va devoir vraiment surmonter
cet obstacle pour acquérir une
réputation et une solide si vous voulez
et alors il va au fond il aux îlots il
ils envient beaucoup les peintres son
âge qui commence à réussir que ce soit
que ce soit
voilà et lui à ce moment là il est
vraiment oui il en est n'a seulement ici
cherche comment parvenir à les égaler
et puis tout à coup c'est tout se passe
très vite à 32 ans il trouve c'est
vraiment ce sont des trouvailles
d'abord la boîte de campbell soup qui va
reproduire
puis dupliquer à l'infini les dollars
qui va à eux aussi dupliquer à l'infini
et puis les lithographies de deux photos
de stars
il commence par nalinnes monroe ensuite
sur un très vite elvis presley liz
taylor lui même etc etc
voilà grosso modo les trois trouvaille
d'andy warhol concentré en très peu de
temps et qui vont lui permettre en un
rien de temps décalé légales et les plus
grands exactement
alors en plus j'ajouterai la série des
catastrophes
il a aussi peint des suicides des
accidents de voiture
la bombe atomique la femme de série des
chaises des criques qui sont d'une
beauté on dirait enfin c'est c'est d'une
telle pureté quand on les voit et c'est
et le malaise est démultiplié par le
fait d'être présenté en séries
donc il a 7 il n'a pas inventé la
sérigraphie mais le fait de l'adapter à
ses formes en séries ça on peut avoir 40
50 60 mêmes éléments sur un mur donne
une force incantatoire ça on est on est
on est hypnotisé tous les gens qui m'en
ont parlé
dès les premières expositions ne venez
pas il sortait de deux des expositions
chaos tellement c'était si vous voulez
c'est comme s'il mettait le doigt sur
les névroses en fait ils mettent ils
vous présentez une loupe sur tout le
côté dérangeant qu'il s'agit de l'argent
de la mort une marilyn en fait c'est un
commentaire sur la mort elle vient de
mourir quand il fait cette série tableau
mais le choix de sa palette
ses peintures si criardes 6 acide nous
dise quelque chose nous dise cette femme
a été tuée à l'âge de 36 ans parce
qu'elle s'est laissé dépasser par pas
partout le milieu par l'époque et
qu'elle était un produit de consommation
pour les américains comme les soupes
voilà où les bouteilles de coca cola et
d'ailleurs il fait toujours un
commentaire dans la série des soupes
campbell elles sont toutes pareilles
mais tout d'un coup il ya une soupe qui
est complètement tordu ou une soupe dont
l'étiquette est déchiré ce qui veut dire
que la marginalité l'originalité
étaient aussi existantes dans l'amérique
de des années 50
même si les américains ne voulaient pas
le voir il est il introduisait toujours
une sorte comme ça de réflexion qui est
qui vous donner l'accès à une autre
exploration alors que l'on aime ou qu'on
n'aime pas l'art de d'andy warhol ou
andy warhol en tant que grand artiste on
peut le trouver effectivement surestimé
d'ailleurs la critique est assez féroce
avec lui au départ à lui reproche de
faire de l'art grâce à un procédé
mécanique ce qui est vrai et ça n'est
pas encore à la mode
à ce moment là c'est lui qui va
l'imposer au fond ce n'est paru voilà
mai mais on est obligé de reconnaître
quand on voit ces images à quel point
elles sont devenues intégrante elles ont
incarné les années 60 il est très rare
qu'un artiste plastique est à ce point
influence et l'esthétique de son époque
exactement et c'est très étrange parce
qu'effectivement on perd l'unicité de
l'oeuvre d'art normalement une vraie là
elle est unique
là ce n'est plus le cas parce que lui et
ses assistants arrivé en quatre minutes
à faire une toile donc ils peuvent ils
pouvaient en faire plusieurs 2010 en
quelques mois pour les expositions cela
et angie moi je vous pose la question je
le fais parce que c'est ce qu'est ce qui
m'est arrivé je la pose à tout le monde
quand on sort d'une exposition rôle on
transporte avec nous un malaise et
mélancolie le ciel graphie et le procédé
des séries n'a pas nui au fond à
l'émotion on emporte avec nous quelque
chose de très profond
une réflexion sur ces visages qui nous
accompagnent et donc il a réussi aussi
en tant que peintre
je pense qu'il a réussi à ceux à ceux à
nous offrir quelque chose d'absolument
unique
en tout cas il a réussi à devenir riches
et célèbres et c'est ce qu'il voulait
devenir et et dès l'âge de 35 ans au
moment même où il devient une superstar
des arts plastiques il se tourne vers le
cinéma et il va faire des films
absolument à ce moment le premier ce
clip qui dure quatre heures 45 pendant
lequel ils doublent henry victime
il filme son amant qui est pas vraiment
son amant d'ailleurs voulu raconter en
détail dans le livre en train de dormir
puis il va filmer l'empiré state
building
début de la matinée jusqu'à la fin de la
soirée en un plan fixe et puis ensuite
il y avoir plein plein de films d'andy
warhol fait toujours avec 3 3 $ et 600
ce tous plus ennuyeux les uns que les
autres
moi de mon point de vue et du point de
vue d'un peu près tout le monde puisque
quand il ya pourtant dieu sait s'il est
célèbre et adulée pour faire les gens
s'endorment aux premières sorte avant la
voûte femmes cep sa liste de ses films
que de les voir à gênés que quand même
c'est lui le premier avons racheté les
droits de orange mécanique
donc il fait son premier range mécanique
kevin hill en 1965 donc quelques cinq
ans avant avant avant le le seul et
unique orange mécanique mais c'est
tellement mauvais même là parce qu'il
voulait c'était pour lui ce qui était
important c'était un cinéma expérimental
donc même les défauts là une mauvaise
prise de son une image floue une
pellicule grainé c'était important
cette étape et si vous voulez il
s'opposait à hollywood et c'est sa
manière à lui de proposer un un regard
aux antipodes de hollywood il est vrai
que quand on voit les red et des
rétrospectives aujourd'hui c'est à périr
d'ennui sassus bien d'accord avec vous
et d'ailleurs alors la factory qui est
très célèbre donc son atelier va servir
aussi de rendez vous à tous les acteurs
qui veulent tourner avec andy warhol
parce que c'est très chic de tourner
avec andy warhol
ça va devenir le rendez-vous aussi de
deux musiciens aussi célèbre que lou
reed et le velvet underground dont il
devient le producteur et dont il dessine
la dernière à auch est d'ailleurs on
voit d'ailleurs lac le nouveau style
andy warhol ça n'a plus rien à voir avec
les pochettes de tout à l'heure qu'il y
avait dix ans avant quand il dessinait
les pochettes de 2,2 du label blue dot
il va se faire tirer dessus par valérie
solanas il va être même déclaré mort
cliniquement 1
il est en sursis à part te lasser c'est
un miracle qu'ils soient sortis vivants
alors que normalement il était mort il
était mort oui une seule balle a
traversé tous les organes vitaux souffre
le coeur et grâce à un médecin qui a
ouvert la cage thoracique qui a fermé
un massage cardiaque il a pu être sauvé
mais c'est un enfer c'est à dire que là
nous sommes en juin 68 et il souffrira à
jamais il va le voir porter des corsets
il est il disait j'ai plus de couture
qu'une robe de dior et c'est vrai qu'il
ya des photos d'avedon où il est torse
nu c'est absolument insensé la manière
dont on la découpe et charcuter pour le
sauver et non seulement ce sont des
douleurs physiques mais ce sont des
moutons des douleur émotionnelle et
intellectuelle parce que cette femme en
lui tirant dessus à créer en lui la peur
la moindre portière de voiture qui
claquait la moins de personnes qui
arrivent à l'improviste
ils étaient terrorisés donc jusqu'à la
fin de sa vie bien que travaillant
beaucoup continue à peindre à faire des
films et a multiplié les expériences il
va aussi créer le magazine interview
il sera un homme qui souffrira est qui
qui qui aura peur et une interview
puisque vous en parlez
voilà un magazine alors là il apporte
vraiment quelque chose autant aussi
belle dans le cinéma il fait de l'art
contemporain est ennuyeux dans le cinéma
autant dans la presse il fait vraiment
quelque chose à tel point d'ailleurs que
thierry ardisson en sortira une
contrefaçon
quelques décennies plus tard et il sera
obligé de changer le titre d'ailleurs en
entrevue mais un magazine entièrement
basé sur les interviews extrêmement bien
ministre est alors parce que parlions de
la première photo de robert mapplethorpe
c'est donc c'est dans l'interview c'est
warhol qui le découvrent il a eu l'idée
de faire de me demander à truman capote
à la fin de sa vie une série
d'entretiens pendant un an
pendant tous les mois un portrait le 2-2
de truman par quelques de enfin une
interview de truman avec un personnage
dont qu'il avait sous ses trouvailles la
qualité des interviews du tout et
dérange pas quand même les numéros les
uns après les autres
c'est basquiat qui va lui redonner le
goût de la peinture basquiat qui à 21
ans qui est le nouveau phénomène de la
peinture mais lui de la vraie peinture
axa vrai peintre basquiat qui ce qu'ils
se tapent en plus toute l'histoire de la
peinture qu'il va repeindre à sa
bannière et leur rencontre va donner
envie à andy warhol de se remettre à
peindre ils vont faire quand même parle
de toi lance un ensemble un oui et puis
c'est à un moment où la vie privée de
warhol et tragiques sont son compagnon
metz et et platonique donné de le
quitter
donc le début des années 80 il se sent
très seul
mélancolique et tout d'un coup les
jeunes peintres ski à bastia mais à
keith haring il y a du punch nabeul il
aime tous
pourquoi parce que warhol proposer une
vision décomplexée du monde de l'art
c'est pas du tout la liste maudit qui
est dans un tour qui de temps en temps
livre un chef-d'oeuvre
non c'est quelqu'un qui aime l'argent
qu'ils jouent le jeu des cotes des
ventes aux enchères et ces jeunes
artistes veulent être louis j c'est
l'écran mentor le lien le plus profond
soeur avec bastia ils vont faire deux à
quatre mains plus de 243 l'ensemble
malheureusement basquiat est quand même
tellement fragilisé par la drogue que la
première exposition qu'ils font à de si
mauvaises critiques
on reproche si vous voulez avoir le
vampiriser basquiat et à bastia de
s'être laissé vampirisé par warhol
basquiat est trop fragile
il ne le supportera pas et pourtant
c'est un des moments où warhol est
vraiment généreux et gentil
ils essaient de le de l'éloigner de la
drogue
il lui laisse de vivre dans un cet
atelier alors que le bas ce qui a peu
paie assez rarement et très
irrégulièrement le loyer il est
bienveillant à son égard et ça va être
aussi une souffrance et une douleur la
rupture la rupture en tout bien tout
honneur parce que ce qui a été et héros
sexuelles avec avec warhol c'est vrai
que ça aide sera était à la fois un
chant du cygne
avant sa mort et en même temps aussi une
ultime douleur il meurt à 58 ans après
une opération de la vésicule andy warhol
et à ce moment là le monde entier le
monde entier est totalement stupéfait 1
personne ne s'attendait à cette mort là
il avait échappé à l'assassinât
programmé par valérie solanas el-himer
une façon qui paraît stupide
oui parce qu'il avait une telle horreur
les hôpitaux il avait vu son père mourir
à cinquante deux ans dans des conditions
tragiques dans un hôpital il avait vu sa
mère charcuter dans un hôpital dont
qu'il détestait les hôpitaux et l'idée
d'un bistouri pour lui c'était atroce
donc il s'était tourné vers les
médecines parallèles les crises qu'ils
étaient couverts de cristaux par exemple
sous ses vêtements parce qu'il pensait
que les cristaux aller le recharger en
énergie positive
évidemment tout ça ça ne marche pas donc
la vésicule biliaire c'est comme la
peine dit si tu sais rien il aurait dû
être sauvé et aujourd'hui il dit serait
toujours parmi nous normalement mais il
a été son propre pire ennemi et
d'ailleurs je trouve que c'est une
pirouette droit rôle yens parce que son
corps va avoir une autopsie
et c'est comme ça je termine le livre
quelqu'un qui détestait autant les
hôpitaux et les pistes oury quoi de pire
que d'être enlevé les d'être d'être
livré à une autopsie
j'aimerais bien savoir ce que frédéric
sojcher pense qu'andy warhol alors andy
warhol cinéaste d'abord et andy warhol
en général mais le cinéaste un
actionnaire ça finisse conceptuel c'est
un cinéaste qui fait de l'art
contemporain c'est pas du cinéma mais
c'est intéressant comme démarche
artistique comme concept et comme comme
souligné frédéric sessa s'y ennuie de
voir la plupart des thunes d'andy warhol
ils sont pas vus pour être vu dans la
totalité ils sont plus vus comme des
intéressant comme comme un essai
artistique en fait est par contre je le
vois comme quelqu'un maintenant minable
pas très comme un formidable artiste
généreux ouvert et surtout précurseur de
cette idée que chacun on aurait notre
heure de célébrité peut être grâce à
vous frédéric derrière rossi et donc
comment est-ce qu'on est rentré dans
cette société le médiatique et donc il
avait quand même une perception très
avant gardiste du monde et c'est
quelqu'un d'important comme pas
seulement comme cinéaste mais comme
artiste de manière générale mais les
bellegarde que les films sont
complètement inconnu mais le plus grand
chose mais en tant qu'artiste évidemment
c'est une icône qu'on connaît a très
bien et puis tous ces tableaux la cg
l'impression je les ai vus depuis
toujours donc c'est oui c'est
iconographique bas score oui c'est vrai
que nous on a pas mal de on passe pas
mal de temps à aller chercher des textes
qui sont inconnus et est de plus en plus
souvent on lit aussi ce qu'a fait
notamment valérie solanas donc j'avoue
que je lis à toute l'histoire qui m'a
été transmise par on va dire l'héritage
culturel international
et puis maintenant je trouve ça super de
pouvoir aussi contrebalancer cette
chose-là en en allant lire scum
manifesto par exemple ou des choses
qu'elle a pu écrire donc voilà je trouve
qu andy warhol c'est aussi avec cette
construction de personnages cet attrait
de l'argent et et ce travail de
sérigraphie de reproduction c'est aussi
une très belle figure en un emblème
aussi de ce qui est devenu aussi
certaines positions artistique et et
voilà donc je n'ai pas grand chose à
dire sur andy warhol à part ça en tout
cas merci tous les 4 andy warhol le
renard blanc c'est paru chez alary merci
d'avoir participé à cette émission
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
m